نظم عماله شركه النقل في تونس وقفه
احتجاجيه في ساحه الحكومه بالقصبه في تونس
العاصمه دعت اليها الجامعه العامه للنقل
الاحتجاجا على عدم صرف منح شهر نساء منح
شهر ديسمبر ديسمبر الاعمال الشركه وتاتي
الوقفه التي تسببت في اضطرابات في حركه
النقل في سياق احتجاجات جامعه النقل
التابعه للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل على
ما تصفه بتجاهل الحكومه لمطالبها واهمها
رفض خصاصه مؤسسات النقل كما من المنتظر ان
تنفذ الجامعه اضرابا عاما في قطاعات النقل
الجويه
والبحريه يومي الخامس والعشرين والسادس
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري
من تونس معنا مراسله الجزيره ميساء
الفطناسي ميساء هل انت تقدر هذه الوقفه
الاحتجاجيه ام مازالت مستمرتها
او قل عدد الحاضرين في والمشاركين في هذه
الوقفه الاحتجاجيه التي ينفذها اعوان شركه
نقل تونس وهنا نتحدث عن تحديدا اعوان
النقل التابعين لسلك سلك الحافلات وايضا
السكك الحديديه ربما العاملين والمشاركين
في هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه وهم في انتظار
ما ستفضي اليها مشاورات الطرف الحكومي مع
النقابي حول المطالب التي نفذت من اجلها
هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه وهي مطالب ماديه
بالاساس تتعلق بالمطالبه بصرف المستحقات
الماليه لاعوان شركه نقل تونس لشهر ديسمبر
هناك حقيقه همم اضطراب ليس في عمليات نقل
المسافرين والناس اليوم فقط وانما ايضا في
مواقف
المحتاجين حيث ان البعض يتحدث عن ان راتب
او رواتب شهر ديسمبر تصرف الى حد الان
بينما يؤكد البعض بان رواتب شهر ديسمبر تم
صرفها ولكن بشكل متاخر وهو ما ادى الى همم
تاخر همم حصول العاملين عليها الى حد الان
واليوم ليطالب المحتجون فقط
بمنح شهر ديسمبر وبعض المستحقات الماليه
الاخرى اذا هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه لعمال
قطاع النقل بشركه نقل تونس احدثت اضطرابا
في عمليات النقل وسفر التونسيين اليوم
خصوصا واننا اليوم هو اليوم الاول يوم
العمل الاول الذي يعيش التونسيون في هذه
السنه الجديده وبعد انتهاء عطله الثلاثي
الاول كثير من الناس يقصدون اعمالهم
والبعض ايضا يقصد مقر دراسته وغيرها من
الحاجيات اليوميه التي يقضيها الثانيه
التونسيون وجدوا انفسهم اليوم امام غياب
لوسائل النقل للميتوهات والحافلات وهو ما
احدث اقترابا في عمليات التونسيه يذكر انه
يبدو انه همم ايضا ينتظر ان يكون هناك
اضراب لعمال موظفي قطاع النقل الجوي
والبحري ايضا هل يعني ما المعلومات عن ذلك
متى يفترض ان ان يكون ذلك وهل يمكن همم ان
يوقف ام انهم ماضون في في عزمهم هذا
هذا ما كنت اتحدث عنه وعثمان منذ اسبوع
تقريبا اقرت الجامعه العامه للنقل التابعه
للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل اقرت اضرابا
عاما
عن العمل في قطاع النقل برا وبحرا وجوا
وهو الاضراب الذي كانت تونسيون ينتظرون ان
يكون له تاثير كبير على حياتهم يوميه
الخامس والعشرين والسادس والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري هذا الاضراب سببه اساسا هو
احتجاج الموظفين واحتجاج جامعه النقل في
تونس على توجهات ربما الحكومه بخصصه
مؤسسات النقل العمومي في تونس اضافه الى
مطالب اخرى تتعلق همم كما تصفه الجامعه
تنص الحكومه من تنفيذ ومن الالتزام
بالتعهدات وبالاتفاقيات السابقه مع الطرف
النقابي ربما قد يعالج الامر وقد يلغى
الاضراب اذا ما تم تخصيص جلسات تشاور بين
الطرف النقابي والطرف الحكومي حول هذه
المساله تحديدا ايضا ربما قد يتجه هذا
اليوم وهو اليوم الذي توقف فيه النشاط
ولكن لم يعلم فيه سابقا عن اضراب عام قد
يتجه الامر الى سيناري وهات اخرى في
انتظار ما ستصفر عنه وجلسات التشاور بين
الطرف النقابي والحكومي فيما يتعلق
باحتجاج اليوم تحديدا قطاع النقل منذ فتره
عثمان يشهد اضطرابا كبيرا ويشهد سلسله من
التحركات الاحتجاجيه كان اخرها الشهر
الماضي حيث نفذ ايضا عمال شركه نقل تونس
وقفه الاحتجاجيه ايضا لنفس الاسباب
للمطالبه بصرف المستحقاتهم الماديه وفي
حديث لاحد النقابيين التابعين لجماعه
جامعه النقل يتحدث عن ان وزير النقل عاجز
حسب تعبيره عن وضع او تحديد سقف زمني
للصرف المستحقات الماليه للموظفين في قطاع
النقل والايجاد حلول لهذه
ازمه وذلك لتجنب استمرار او تعطيل
المواطنين الذين يقصدون اا وسائل النقل
العموميه من حافلات ومتروات للتوجه
لاعمالهم ولدراستهم و لقضاء حاجيتهم
اليوميه شكرا جزيلا لك ميساء الفطناسي
المتحدث الثاني